secrets were revealed questions were
answered plans were unfurled and by the
time the dust settled even
secret-identity seemed to be changing
hands now we're here to unpack it all
this is the ending of watchmen season
one explained though Angela a var was
the clear main character for much of the
series at least in Tulsa Watchmen also
featured two other key law enforcement
officers whose lives were forever tied
to the events of the original comic in
the HBO series we meet an older version
of Laurie Blake the second Silk Spectre
and dr. Manhattan's ex-girlfriend and
looking glass a Tulsa cop who happened
to be near Ground Zero on the day Adrian
Veidt unleashed his alien creature to
save humanity as the season ends both
Laurie and LG find themselves in the
same place with the same agenda arrest
Adrian Veidt for his genocide old crimes
and keep pushing their investigation as
high as it needs to go in spite of
White's insistence otherwise because the
world will end yeah people keep saying
that but it never seems to happen so
what happens to them next well it's easy
to see them teaming up on the future of
the Veidt investigation and following it
all the way through by the time it's all
over looking glass might even join the
FBI and where he might finally be able
to move on for the last shreds of her
superhero past Watchmen the comic
famously reached its climax with the
reveal that Adrian Veidt was behind the
death of the comedian and that it was
part of his own massive scheme to save
humanity by uniting the worlds behind a
common alien enemy to do that he
teleported a giant squid creature into
the heart of New York City killing 3
million people
veidt's bounced around a lot since 85 he
spent a lot of time holed up in his
Arctic sanctuary Karnak then was trapped
on Europa for several years and upon
finally returning to earth he summoned
all of his ego and intellect and stopped
lady true from taking dr. Manhattan's
power with that in mind he was convinced
he'd be worshipped as the world's
smartest man get again Laurie Blake and
Looking Glass had other ideas though and
armed with the video Veidt made for
newly elected president Robert Redford
in 1985 they decided to arrest him for
the deaths of the three million in New
York and for the conspiracy that had
continued
since via intermittent squid rain
engineered by bite after a strange trial
on Europa Veidt is presumably headed for
another trial on earth but this time
he's likely to have plenty of defenders
who hail him as a visionary who did what
he had to in order to save the world for
all we know Veidt won't even survive
long enough for a trial but that might
be with lorry and LG are angling for
as for Redford who became a
co-conspirator invites plan when he took
office Blake makes it clear that it
would be fine with her to bring the
president up on charges as well which
means the United States government is
about to be rocked by a lot of upheaval
much of Watchmen season finale is
devoted to explaining exactly what was
really going on with the mysterious lady
true and it turns out there's quite a
history to mine lady truth the smartest
woman in the world was born to a mother
who stole a semen sample from adrian
veidt's private vaults true inherited
veidt's intellect ambition and
insatiable ego and it all led her to
believe that she was the only one in the
world worthy of holding dr. Manhattan's
power if I can take his power I can fix
the world as it turns out true was
planning to kill Manhattan all along and
her millenium clock house to the device
that would have allowed her to do it
Adrian Veidt was able to stop her at the
last moment with a reign of frozen squid
but while lady true is dead her legacy
is not beyond the Cologne of trues own
mother who served as her daughter is
still alive and her massive corporation
and its many Holdings will go to her
will beyond learn the right lessons from
her mother's hubris will she right the
wrongs of true or will she in time adopt
the same egotistical outlook on the
world
lady trues planned to take dr.
Manhattan's power for herself nearly
worked in part because she was using the
7th cavalry plan to also take dr.
Manhattan's power as cover the cavalry
an extension of the racist organization
known as Cyclops that William Reeves
spent nearly all of his adult life
fighting has been scheming for years to
incite an overthrow of President Redford
and their fortunes shifted dramatically
when they learned Manhattan was back on
earth armed with this knowledge and the
resources of Joe King jr. they developed
their own plan to essentially take over
the US government in the end their plan
failed and true used her own resources
to vaporize all of Cyclops key leader
ship including Joe Keene senior the
Cyclops is headless but that doesn't
mean it's dead white supremacy has been
shown to have a particularly insidious
hold on this world and it's doubtful
that organized versions of it will
vanish so quickly the season finale of
Watchmen managed to pack a lot into its
runtime but one thing the episode didn't
address was the identity of one of
watchman's strangest to new characters
lube man the character so named because
of his greased skin-tight silver suit
appeared only once in the series proper
and made a very fast but unforgettable
exit via a storm drain
ever since fans of the show have been
wondering who exactly was under all that
silver the season finale didn't tell us
but HBO's canonical supplement to the
series PD pedia seems to have spelled it
out the Compendium named for Laurie
Blake's FBI subordinate Dale PD hinted
in previous entries that PD himself may
have adopted the lube man identity and
the entries added after the final
episode aired all but confirm its PD was
Lube man and he was snooping through the
investigation via his secret identity
Angela a bars life was forever changed
by the events of watchman's first season
she found out the grandfather she never
met was hooded justice and that he was
still alive and still working as a
vigilante she found out the truth about
her friend and mentor she had to reveal
her husband was secretly dr. Manhattan
only to lose him hours later and she had
to figure out how to pick up the pieces
after John died once and for all with
all this in mind Watchmen season 1
approaches its final moments with the
promise of a new beginning for Angela
with her children and her grandfather
sleeping safely inside she walks to her
swimming pool with a miraculously
unbroken egg swallows it and remembers
something dr. Manhattan told her so you
can put them in this egg and if I ate it
I could walk on water the season stopped
short of visually confirming that
Manhattan did imbue that last egg with
his powers therefore passing them on to
Angela
but according to creator Jamin Lindelof
there's no real ambiguity there there's
no reason to thank all those things John
said were leading nowhere and after all
Angela was bathed in blue light on the
poster for the series the message is
clear Angela a bar is the new dr.
Manhattan whether we got to see her walk
on water
or not check out one of our newest video
right here plus even more looper videos
about your favorite shows are coming
soon subscribe to our YouTube channel
and hit the bell so you don't miss a
single one
you